[音楽]
オラン受けた
ハロー
2人のライフワークの始まりは22年前
ここ日本からでした
お互いの作品に関わりを持ち
次第に共同制作を始めます
そして野外べ誰でも自由に触れられる
焼き物の作品を作るようになりました
それはまるで船を作りながら海渡っていく
冒険の4でした
20年前の夏
c の許可を得ていカ月かけて
高級のバーに年度デー
これぐらいの形を作り
廃材を使って焼きました
製作中にどのタイプに対応
完成した作品は
それをの広場どんなつけました
しかし
ある日
この作品は壊されてしまいました
作品を形作ってた3トンの年度は
が冷気になってしまったのですあまりのショックに私は子供を打って市役所の担当者
まで作品の破片を持って行きました
納得できる説明はなかったのですが壊された原因の1つは
場所と人の関係を考えなかったからだと気づいました
そこで実際に地域の人とコミュニケーションを取りすす一緒に制作をすることで
そこでしかを生み出すことのできないものを作りたいと思いました
この街に作品残したいという2人の強い思いがあった時
再び公共の公園で製作する許可をもらえました
杉の作品のテーマは
人と人が向き合える場
場所
と作品の蜜を沙華アワセる
ビジョンです
この作品が公園で制作していたので
色々な人が声をかけてくれました
一緒に粘土やレンガを運び
鎌滝も力を合わせたことで
一作品と人の繋がりられてきました
3年間作ったの作品はその場所で焼き
熱や圧力で岩のようになり
えっとその場所に残り続きます
将来とあき穂のの広場です
私たちがなぜこのような空間作ろうと思ったのか
ベネズエだにある石で作られた野外劇場で感じた様々な音の響き
アメリカの大木の kcud で経験した
包み込まれるような感覚から in スプレー種の得たからです
音に進まれる不思議な空間を粘土で表現したくなりました
そのインスピレーションに大谷高野無理が飛ぶ
田んぼに囲まれた里山が砂がりました
遊びダンス音楽劇と自然が一緒になって新しい表現が生まれる場所
焼き物の反響板を持つ野外劇所
それが止まぬ広場野外劇場です
焼き物の歴史は古く
任満6000年も前から続いています
しかし今回私たちが挑戦するような強大な焼き物の前例がありません
d 人がクリエになるに失礼
自分たちの能力や総菜の限界に迫ることは
構造上も経済的にも大きなで介です
私たち悪い祝 osho 市で代々釜をつくってきた
と外科建築家測量士
そして歯医者さんからも教わりながら制作に取り掛かりました
最良しているところをねそこで何をしてるんですか
反響ばインドでわーすごいですね
大変そうですねいつかぜするんですか
まあ今日明日に追われないなけど一緒にやれば早くありますよ
こういうときのために
軍手はいつも用意してありました
ペンという
少しずつ一緒に左右する人が増えていき自分たちのビジョンがより現実になってきまし
た
桓武2件
デューオ事件
来れる時に
できることを
バケツリレーで粘土を運んでる人粘土をこねている人
おにぎり作ってる人何もしないでずーっと喋ってる人
大きな葉パオカーサにして走り回ってる子供たち
すでに劇が始まっています多くの人が参加する中で出会いや分かる時には代理つもあり
ました
ある時
大夫で30トンオス見上げてた反響板から7頭が崩れる出来事がありました
より早く治そうと工場のラインのようなやり方を押し付けてきた人がいましたが多くの
人は機械的な最後に反対でした
なぜなら
津市と関わり
その場でしかできないティ母の体験するなために
参加したい人が多かったからです
早くできればいいと考えている人はほとんどいませんでした
ようやく釜を作る段階
一つ28キロのレンガを積み重ねて窯を作ります
こうメートルの高さまで熱が逃げないように組み上げていきますそれはマッサに200
トンのパズルです
ここまで来るのにすでに周りの田んぼの稲刈りを14回も見てしまいました
終わりが見えない塩と酢作ろうぞの中
ビジョンが失ってしまいそうでした
土路にこの時期んわ
仲間があまり集まりませんでした
休みの日にレンガ運びたい人っていないでしょ
あれっあビビるかもしれないいけるよいるからわからん
それでもまた覗きに来る人もいました
まだ終わってないの
でならあります4を
こうしていい良いよ釜が完成しました
年度は高い温度で焼かれると医師になり
二度とスチは戻りません
この反響孫焼き固めるには40日かけて
1200度上がるまで焼き続ける必要がありました
鎌滝は一発勝負失敗は許されません
もしも焼いてる途中で爆発したら
うまく温度が上がらなかったら
今まで b 所を共にしてきた人たちそして自分たちが費やした資金や時間を考えると
不安で落ち着きませんでした
40日間の釜焚きはマラソンです
火を入れて最初は
音楽でいう moderate
あのじっくりキープします
そして窯の温度あ
だんだんアレイ風呂のように早く上げていき
最後には全力で召し上げます
キャンプ生活しながら無心に滝続きました
連日の寝不足で
頭おかしくなりそうというか実際におかしくなりました
そして最後に1本のアカマツを投げ入れ
鎌滝は終了
本当に上手く焼けてるからカワイイ
さらに冷めるまで40日間お待たなければなりません
2年の試作3年の反響はいい
10年の窯そして1年をかけて窯を解体すると
さなぎから蝶が羽ばたくように
オカリーナのような反響板が姿を現しました
山に広場野外劇長は
東証完成には
22年予定してましたが
ケーキ曲16年もかかってしまいました
冬季には想定外だからこそ達成できることもあります
このプロジェクトに関わったロベ2000人もの人々それぞれが自分なりに劇場の
イメージを持ってたでしょう
しかしビジョンは単なるイメージとは違います
ビジョンは未来をつくる力です
その力で水の可能性つなげ合わせこのプロジェクトは実現しました
場所の可能性
そこだからできる
人のか載せ誰にでもできることが
時間の可能性時間かければできる
この里山に人が集まり
劇場が完成し
新しい証言が生まれることで
生きた場所に生まれ変わりました
それは私たちが名刺たビジョン
そのものでした
スペースリピ本名馬でピヴォ人のために
人が作った場所
[音楽]
分
wh
ん
持ってん
ani
on air
今
ん
[音楽]
4日
の
me
ん
[音楽]
この強大な反響板空から見ると小石のようにしか
をすいません
しかしその小石に作ったの皆の手の跡が確かに残りこの経験をとして生まれた一人一人
の思いがこれからも新たな物語をすごいで出していくでしょう
皆さんも自分の持っているビジョンに向かって
自分の頬に一人で漕ぐもよし
みんなで協力して以降もよし
さああなたの物語を作るボケの始めましろ
やつ戦績クラビ